this skin is 1900 otherwise known as 19
you think that Skin's worth 19 OverWatch
2 skins are extremely expensive however
the Saga surrounding blizzards
overpriced Cosmetics has reached an
entirely new chapter I wish we were
joking but players have discovered that
you can get skins Faster by using gold
in World of Warcraft everything comes
full circle so World of Warcraft has
this system where you can purchase a
token with in-game gold and convert it
into subscription time but you can also
convert it into Battlenet currency which
can then be used to purchase things in
other blizzard games including OverWatch
credits and fans have discovered that
it's actually a faster way of getting
these credits than grinding overwatch's
weekly challenges I'd like to say that
it doesn't get any worse but it's been
discovered that the in-game patchumari
gun charm cost more there than it does
in real life OverWatch pachamari
keychain five dollars it costs more
in-game than out of game oh no
laughs